Fick dich weg, du Robo-Fürst!
Boah, Kass.
So, auf geht's.
Irgendwie, dass es heute klappt.
ASMR-FPS, ja.
Boah, Kass, Alter.
Moment hier, wenn ich jetzt ASMR-Stream mache, da bräuchte ich jetzt noch irgendwelche...
Machen wir nicht, aber...
Hier, sowas bräuchte man da.
Ja, außerdem bräuchte ich einen OnlyFans-Account und bräuchte Ausschnitt-Kamera.
Läuft das Ganze besser.
Aber die ganzen ASMR-Streamer, besser gesagt auf Twitch hauptsächlich Streamerinnen,
Stream... Stream... Stream... Stream-Innen, jetzt hab ich's.
Ja, aber was ja da voll angesagt ist in solchen ASMR-Streams und Videos,
ist, dass die Leute sich so eine Plastiktüte nehmen und dann sagen dann...
Ah, excellent.
So, und dann, dann machen die da irgendwie so eine halbe Stunde mit rum.
OnlyFans, ja.
Was machen wir heute?
Ähm...
Heute gucken wir uns Flutter an, ich hab keine Ahnung davon.
Ich hab heute Morgen ein Video geguckt zu Flutter 2.
Und dass man damit angeblich jetzt offizielle Desktop-Apps machen kann.
Ich hab absolut keinen plassen Schimmer davon.
Ich hab das vor drei Jahren oder so mal, als das relativ neu war, installiert.
Und hab mein Projekt angekündigt.
Und das war's.
Bei mir schneit's übrigens auch.
Guck mal.
Bei mir schneit's auch.
Oh, huge Vorschaubild.
Large.
Ja, äußerst large Twitter.
Massive large.
Weiß nicht, was Twitter sich so unter large vorstellt.
Aber ich hab da eine andere Vorstellung von large als Twitter.
Jetzt, jetzt erkennt man alles.
Guck mal hier.
So viel Schnee.
Aber jetzt ist schon wieder alles weg.
Och, was haben wir denn noch?
Alles auf.
Chat hab ich doch schon.
Hot.
Oh, Katzcam.
Ich frag mich grad, wo die...
Jetzt, wo du's sagst.
Ich frag mich grad, wo die liegt.
Ich glaub, die ist unten im Schrank oder so.
Da versteckt die sich immer und liegt dann da irgendwie gefühlt zwölf Stunden drin.
Wenn's hier langweilig ist.
Wie sprechen die Jubantu-Leute Flutter aus?
Das ist ne gute Frage.
Flutter.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß.
Gibt's bestimmt, gibt's bestimmt irgendeinen geilen Aussprung.
Wie gesagt, ich hab gar keine Ahnung davon.
Im Schrank.
Warum ist das Toss, wenn die Katze im Schrank liegt?
Ich mach mal kurz meine VM an.
Hoffentlich startet die heute.
Ja, nice.
Flütter.
Ne, das Flütter, das klingt eher nach Baguette-Aussprache.
Oh, guck mal, ich hab neue Icons.
Was ist da los?
Warum hab ich neue Icons?
Meine Icons sind anders, als das letzte Mal noch.
Ach, das liegt an dem Emoji-Font, den wir installiert haben.
Stimmt.
Keck.
Wait.
Wir haben ja jetzt, wir haben jetzt ja vollen Emoji-Support im Terminal.
Massive.
Und Twitter-Emoji-Support.
Vorher hatten wir nur diese komischen Tweemoji.
Ne, ne, jetzt haben wir Tweemoji, davor hatten wir nur Joypixels.
Und Twitter-Emojis sind viel.
Moment.
Viel mehr.
Wo siehts aus?
Zero Stripes.
So.
Flutter Desktop.
Ich brauch irgendeine Anleitung.
Ich hab davon ehrlich gesagt, also es ist nicht gefaked.
Ich hab da wirklich keine Ahnung von.
Ich hab mir nur gedacht.
Wir probieren das einfach mal aus.
Easy.
Der Informatiker underscore ist auch am Start.
Der kennst du mit sowas bestimmt aus.
Ok dann.
Erkennst du dich aus.
Hehehe.
Hahaha.
Was?
Leute, ich bin übrigens immer noch am überlegen, ob ich mir endlich, endlich das Vera Feinmechaniker Set kaufen soll.
Also natürlich gleich das für 76 Euro, war keine halbe Sache hier, ne?
Aber es kostet halt.
I fix it sagt, insofern, dass du immer die Bits wechseln musst.
Für kleinen Bastelkram ist es tatsächlich ganz gut, wenn man für jede Größe was hat.
Sind das alles Torx oder was ist das?
Ne, ne guck mal, das sind Torx und, Moment, das sind auch irgendwelche komischen Nüsse oder so.
Okay, ne, das brauch ich vielleicht doch nicht.
Ah, keine Ahnung, ich, was will ich mit Flutter machen? Ausprobieren.
Ich hab, ich hab legit absolut keinen blassen Schimmer von.
Ähm, mal gucken, also angeblich seit Flutter 2 geht das auf dem Desktop.
Also es ging vorher schon auf dem Desktop, aber angeblich unterstützen die das jetzt offiziell.
Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt.
Was die da, was die da machen.
Haben wir hier überhaupt noch, haben wir noch irgendwelche Sachen übrig vom letzten, vom Sonntag?
Okay, wir machen jetzt Exquisite Trick.
Äh, Bookmark.
Dass ich vielleicht Sachen, dass wir nächsten Sonntag noch was gucken können.
Uhu.
Save.
New Folder.
Excellent.
Und jetzt kann ich den ganzen Kreml hier eigentlich schließen.
Bam.
Warum geht denn das so langsam?
Ah, okay.
Nice.
Flutter ist Multi-Plattform, ja.
Schreiben sie zumindest, mal gucken wie gut.
Es gibt ja noch mehr Sachen, die sagen, sie sind Multi-Plattform und zacken.
Ha.
Zum Beispiel, die Microsoft, äh, das was jetzt Maui wird, heißt auch so, oder?
Das sackt richtig unter Linux, also Xamarin unter Linux war Massive, Massive, Crap.
So, wie installiert man Flutter?
Guck mal, gibt's das im Paket?
Neue Repos.
Ah, yes.
New Mobile App.
Okay, bevor ich meine VM komplett versaue, ich mach mal einen Snapshot von.
By the way, wieder ein Grund dafür, warum vor allem der Workstation besser ist als der Player.
Elektron größer Flutter.
Mal abwarten.
Du hast vor kurzem ein Rant-Video gesehen zu Flutter.
Ja, das ist ja ein Google-Produkt.
Das würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es da so ein paar, äh, over-engineerte Seiten gibt von Flutter und ein paar...
Dinger, die nicht so geil sind.
Weißt du, was ich, was ich auch nicht so ganz verstehe?
Google war damals mit dem ersten Angular-JS, so eines der ersten, die ein richtig cooles Frontend, also so, so eine von diesen neuen Generationen Frontend-Frameworks hatten.
Und die haben's echt komplett verkackt.
Angular ist voll auf dem, auf dem ab, auf dem absteigenden Ast jetzt.
Aber das ist halt Google-Taktik.
Ich weiß, es gab...
Es gab noch mehr, aber das war so eines der ersten richtigen Hype-Frameworks und irgendwie hat's Google voll verschissen.
Aber eins finde ich ja echt gut, also vielleicht soll ich das mal installieren, während ich hier laber.
Eins finde ich ja relativ gut, äh, dass sich jetzt bei den großen JavaScript-Frameworks nicht allzu, allzu viel tut.
Sondern dass im Prinzip React, Angular und, äh, genau, dass da Angular und Vue ist.
Also React, Angular, Vue.
Was, welche Sensoren anzusprechen?
Moment, was?
Wo meinst du, was ist das?
Das Einzige, was den Flutters sagt, ist, die Sensoren anzusprechen.
Ja gut, das hängt ja wahrscheinlich von der Plattform ab, ne?
Also, was die jeweilige Plattform bietet.
Kommt halt drauf an, was für Sensoren.
Ja, die Svelte-Boys, die müssen doch bis sie, die müssen doch bis sie was machen, dass sie da dabei sind.
Also rein von der Verbreitung her und von dem, was angesagt ist und letztendlich, wenn man vielleicht auch mal sogar nach Jobs zu, Jobs guckt.
Dann ist halt React, Angular.
Dann ist halt React, Angular und Flutter.
Sprich, ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich hab ne, ich hab ne lustige Stellenanzeige gesehen heute.
Wo ich nur den Anfang geil fand.
Computerfuzzi? Dann werden sie doch unser neuer.
Paintschamp.
Wollt ihr nicht auch schon immer mal Computerfuzzi sein?
Ich weiß nicht, es wirkt, es wirkt auf mich so.
Ich fühle mich beleidigt, ey, sag ich, ich kanns verstehen.
Es wirkt auf mich so, als wollte man voll cool klingen, ja?
Und, und es hat es nicht geschafft.
Also, das hätten wir irgendwie anders schreiben können.
Ich finde Computerfuzzi klingt so gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Wenn einer, wenn einer geschrieben hätte.
Hey ihr geilen, super agilen Cloud-Native.
Poggers, Cagweight, sonstwas.
Dann hätte ich mich angesprochen gefühlt, ja?
Gar kein Peps mehr.
Sprich, ist angesprochen.
Okay, das mag ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es Gbait ist oder ernsthaft.
Aber hey, ich mein, ich finde es ja gut.
Dann hat es zumindest die Wirkung nicht ganz verfehlt, ja?
Der Aufzählungspunkt links ist, ah ja, was macht denn der da eigentlich?
Ah, ist halt HTML.
Ich mein, hey, guck mal.
Die machen Fenster.
Die machen kein HTML.
Auch kein Windows.
Oh, Paintschamp wird es, ich weiß.
Xeroxino, dankeschön für den Sub.
What?
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Warum will das Java?
Das kommt mir eigentlich normalerweise nicht aufs System drauf.
Android.
Ach, das ist wegen Android.
Ah, verstehe.
Okay, das leuchtet, das leuchtet ein.
Oh Mist, ich muss den Preisschamp neu starten.
Das habe ich ja komplett vergessen.
Der ist ja immer noch broken.
Der ist schon seit den letzten drei Tagen broken.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal einbauen, dass er sich nachts automatisch neu startet oder so.
Der Katz geht es gut.
Okay.
Ja, Standard Java, alles gut.
Yes.
Excellent.
Ja, aber Ballstrikes muss ich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt runtergestellt, wie oft der abfragt.
Und ich werde jetzt nicht mehr so oft geblockt.
Ich kann das sogar ein paar Tage on lassen, ja.
Easy Light, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe Flutter noch nie verwendet.
Endes Mal LX hier dafür genommen.
Und dann?
Das, was abkackt, ist ja der Crawler-Teil, den ich nicht programmiert habe.
Meins kackt natürlich nicht ab.
Habt ihr schon jemals was, was ich programmiert habe, crashen gesehen?
Das kann eigentlich, also, das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Oh, was war das hier jetzt?
What the fuck?
Welcome to Flutter.
Flutter Tool.
Google Analytics.
Ernsthaft?
Die haben Google Analytics in ihr scheiß Kommandozeilen-Tool eingebaut dafür?
Die wolltest du aber gleich wissen, ne?
Okay, oh, was hat der jetzt?
Android Toolchain is not available.
Chrome, developed for web, nicht available.
Kein Android Studio.
Ja, das macht er nicht.
Ich will ja auch mal eine Desktop-App ausprobieren.
Oh, oh.
Flutter, was ist hier los?
Okay.
Flutter was installed on Opt Flutter.
If you intend to use it as a regular user, add your user into the group Flutter users.
Ist es vielleicht besser, man installiert Flutter von Hand, anstatt über einen Paketmanager?
Okay, wie installiert man, okay, Flutter install, wie macht man das offiziell?
Install Linux, okay.
Vielleicht, vielleicht ist das sogar ein bisschen voller.
Shit muss installiert sein.
Snap, MonkaS.
Also bevor ich das mit Snap installiere, dann installiere ich das lieber über einen Paketmanager.
Ne, ne, ne.
Flutter, manuell, manuell klingt gut, manuell.
Excellent.
If you don't want fixed version.
Okay Leute, wir installieren das jetzt mal von Hand.
Die doofe Vermutung, das wird nicht richtig funktionieren hier über den Paketmanager,
wenn er das in so komischen Ordnern hat und man jetzt erstmal User hinzufügen muss und
sowas.
Ich, ich entferne das nochmal schnell.
Wir können es, wir können es immer noch.
Aua, Flutter ist schon fein.
Ja, den kannst du ja immer noch installieren.
MKDier, Flutter, Flutter.
Also ich werde es definitiv nicht über Snap machen.
Auf Snap habe ich nämlich gar keinen Bock.
Einfach Snapshot laden, ja.
Okay, also.
If you don't want fixed version, get source code from Flutter repo.
Excellent, Flutter repo, Clone.
Machen wir.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob man da mit Linux Desktop Apps machen kann.
Und ob die mittlerweile den Webview haben.
Schauen wir mal.
So.
JIT Clone.
Brauchen wir nicht.
JIT sollte ja standardmäßig Master haben.
Oh, oh, Leute, Leute.
Jetzt habe ich.
Dass die noch Master als Branch verwenden.
Das ist ja mal hier.
Triggert.
Ne, ne, ne.
Anzeige ist raus.
Okay, das haben wir gemacht.
Add Flutter Tool to your Paths.
Wie, das liegt einfach da rum oder was?
Liegt jetzt einfach da rum?
Ja, Shell kriegt dich ein.
Bin.
Tatsächlich, das liegt einfach da rum.
Das Flutter Tool.
Ah, dann.
Bam.
Wie, das war es schon?
Optionally pre-download development binaries.
For pre-downloading these.
Ja, das brauchen wir nicht.
Run Flutter Doctor.
Okay.
Excellent.
Oh, jetzt, jetzt.
Ach, das war vorher nur, nur, nur die Hälfte oder so.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt das eigentliche Install oder wie?
Okay, was?
Wie?
Ich habe ein neues Git Repo gemacht mit einem Dockerfile.
Da mit einem Docker Composefile gebaut.
Docker Compose wird standardmäßig nach Master.
Das neue Git Repo hat der Main.
Tja.
Hausgemachte Probleme, ne?
Man hätte es so einfach haben können.
Und es einfach so lassen.
Und es würde alles funktionieren.
Aber nein.
Man muss ja an Dingen rumdockern, die keinen Sinn machen.
Oh.
Ach so, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Alles in Ordnung.
Das passt.
Aber du kannst das garantiert umstellen.
Trotzdem.
Okay.
Das ist Missing.
Es ist nicht schlimm.
So.
Desktop Flutter Support.
Snap.
Ich will kein Snap.
Setup.
Okay.
Flutter Config Enable Linux Desktop.
Alles klar.
Bam.
Wie?
Das war es?
Und, und nun?
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
You Main und, ja, ja, gut.
Ich, ich habe nichts zum Restarten.
Okay.
Sicherstellen, dass der Desktop Enabled ist.
Das erinnert mich voll an Android.
Irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das.
Ich habe nichts zum Restarten.
Okay.
Sicherstellen, dass der Desktop Enabled ist.
Das erinnert mich voll an Android.
Irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das.
Snap.
Weil ich Snap nicht mag.
Flutter Connected Devices.
Excellent.
Okay.
Linux Desktop.
Snap sagt.
Ja, finde ich auch.
You Main, das haben wir doch gerade schon gemacht.
Der Doktor.
Haben wir laufen lassen.
Oh.
Geht nicht.
Aha.
Okay.
Ich muss Zeug installieren.
Also.
Was muss ich für Kram installieren?
Übrigens.
Ich habe hier.
Hier.
Und Ich dachte früher, immer dass heißt Zil Sweet Ficks.
Aber heißt gar nicht.
Ich habe jetzt.
Ich habe jetzt schon einige Konferenztalks und so gesehen.
Die haben das als Klang ausgesprochen.
Klang.
Aber das haben wir doch alles drauf.
Sie Make habe ich doch.
Wir haben eindeutig zu wenig C++ Stilz gemacht hier drauf.
Ninja.
Gleich kommt noch Fortnite waiting les Men perfume St können auch installed wird dauer
installiert.
Wie heißt das Ding hier.
Ja, das ist installiert.
pkg config oder alles braucht installiert und gtk 3 das ist auch
installiert okay also können wir weitermachen was sagt der doktor jetzt
der doktor sagt beim funktioniert exzellent
ok weiter geht's ich gebe was ist leute ich habe jetzt ja gehört dass ihr im
chat schon ein paar leute mit erfahrung was ist die beste flatter idee hat
lässigen schon er nicht einfach sagt lässt sich in einer jetbrain schon
irgendwas wie es code jetzt eine offizielle flatter extension für flutter
extension test test test ist schlecht das
so zu nennen keck wait heißt unser erstes projekt beste
ok flutter flutter flutter und dart extension gibt es da was muss man kurz
kommen ach nee plugins flug was sind das für
ein painstamp bezeichnung wahrscheinlich weil google nicht wollte dass das
flatter genannt wird ok das haben wir gemacht aber gemacht hat alles
funktioniert
and run flatter create my app ok das war das mag ich schon mal dass das sieht
relativ easy aus great my app ok ich mache jetzt eins zu eins mal so wie es
in dem in der anleitung drin steht man weiß ja nie ok ok ok nice cd my app da
wäre ich jetzt auch so drauf gekommen so und da ist jetzt das ganze zeug drin
aha to launch application from command line ok jetzt bin ich aber gespannt ob
das funktioniert
der flatter champion was ist das das basiert auf gtk unter linux oder benutzen
die da bloß in welche base dinge drauf ich dachte flattere rentner komplett
selbst alle control warum brauchen die gtk sollen das oder es ist guck mal ok
es sieht es sieht original aus wie android app die aber in ihrer relativ
gut läuft
text
rendering ist doch jetzt was ich mich jetzt interessiert ist da gtk drunter
was willst du für eine programmieren gar keine ich will jetzt einfach mal
angucken ist da gtk drunter oder benutzen das nur um fenster zu erstellen
oder sowas also sprich ist das hier eigentlich ein gtk button oder ist das
wirklich flatter button den flatter da malt mit fragt mich nicht ob ein gl oder
so also ist flatter unter linux nur nun in gtk rapper ich hoffe mal nicht
okay wir können den button pushen und es funktioniert ich bin begeistert
tastatur shortcuts funktionieren alle nicht die back egal ein eiser ein eiser
button wird gepusht ich weiß nicht so sieht jetzt halt nicht unbedingt eine
normale linux app aus sieht dann aus wie eine mobile app aber das ist ja schon
irgendwo klar sie auch das default template okay
excellent
ist das ein chrome also hot reload also ich habe ja ich habe mich damit nicht
weiter beschäftigt ich dachte dass flatter was komplett eigenes ist also
das ist kein chrome und im endeffekt auch kein kein elektron light oder so
und es ist auch kein rapper für schon bestehende ui sachen sondern so wie ich
das verstanden habe rendert flatter wirklich alles selbst
also dass ist kein gtk button so ein immobilien wie du hast
straight
so also so war das doch needing Sensistence
super cool
Flutter-Extension.
IOS, Test, Web.
Linux. Hier.
Flutter.
Alter, wie viel? 30 Milliarden Sachen, ey.
Wo ist mein Source-Code?
Gibt's nicht.
Overrated. Braucht man nicht.
Warum kein Android-Studio?
Ist das besser?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Matt3F.
Simona, danke schön für den Sub.
Wo ist mein Source-Code?
Ich mein, ich würde dir
ein Lip. Main Dart.
Ah, yes.
Okay, Search.
Also, Leute, die zwei Dinger.
Oder wie? Oder was? Oder wo?
Dart, Flutter.
Reiner Zufall.
Danke schön, Prime Gaming.
Huge Sub.
Ah, CuteMod 2.0 ist am Start.
So, also Install,
Install. Hä?
War mein Aim zu schlecht gerade?
Der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Nice. 94%
Leute.
Ein Sub brauchen wir noch.
Dann haben wir es geschafft.
Lasst euch mal scammen.
Eine Runde.
General Slain, 11 Monate. Danke schön für den Sub.
Das ist ja eins vor Hyper-Subscription.
Would you like to use the recommended VS Code Settings for Dart & Flutter?
Yes.
Okay, ich glaube euch einfach, dass das passt.
Nice, wir haben es geschafft.
Massive.
Der Tains hat Abos verschenkt.
Schon insgesamt 144, Alter.
Keck, wait.
Ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft. Massive. Der Tains hat Abos verschenkt. Schon insgesamt 144, Alter. Keck, wait.
Wer hat was gekriegt? Der Alte hat呢r Stufe 1 Abo gekriegt. Nice Tain fer.
Kampf Kevin auch am Start!
Jucho27!
Now It's the Jana!
Now It's the Na
Merci für die ganzen Subs, jetzt sind wir schon auf Stufe 3!
Habt ihr euch nice jubilen lassen von Twitch. Excellent.
IQ++, ja, bald. Also bald reicht für den Chat nicht mal 5Head.
Da müssen wir erstmal noch rein.
навер monde
ayan
dermen
wir den Kopf schon ein bisschen erweitern in die
Richtung. So, okay.
So, alles jetzt alles
geinstallt. Wunderbar.
Wir haben Syntax-Highlighting, Leute.
Ich fass es nicht. Haben wir auch
My Homepage.
Okay, ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz
verarbeiten, was ich hier sehe.
Ich hab noch nie was mit Dart gemacht
und ich hab noch nie was mit
Flutter gemacht. Also,
Import. Erstmal gucken, haben wir
irgendwie Autocomplete für die Imports.
Package.
Ja, wir haben Autocomplete für die Imports. Okay, alles
klar. Ja, yes.
Also, lass mal kurz
checken, was
ich hier sehe.
Also,
Class MyAppExtendState
Main. Main. Okay, da kann ich mir was darunter
vorstellen.
So macht man anscheinend Functions.
Also, Void.
CagRate.
Int.
Haben wir sowas? Aha, lull.
Das sieht ja relativ
standardmäßig aus.
Oh, das Allerwichtigste.
Ich muss checken,
ob das die Go-Syntax ist für If-Else.
Nein! Nein! Nein, bitte
nicht. Nicht die Go-Syntax
für If-Else. Hört mal auf, Google.
Geh weg. Geh weg.
Das ist so
Painschampig, Alter. Wer macht
denn sowas?
Wer macht so sein If-Else?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Console.
Right.
Nee, hör mal auf. Komm.
Echt, gibt es wirklich jemanden, der die
Go-Syntax mag? Kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen. Muss man eigentlich Semikolon
machen oder so? Das ist doch die
gute If-Else-Syntax.
Was? Näh.
Im Leben nicht.
Die beste If-Else-Syntax ist
entweder
meinetwegen sowas, aber ich persönlich
bin ja für sowas.
Warum nicht so? Sieht doch viel besser aus.
Viel klarer, was da los ist.
Hehe.
Warum...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist ein richtiger Painschamp.
Hawks, vier Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Heute müsst ihr besonders dringend
AdWoblos davor schreiben, wenn ich was sehen soll,
weil ich glaube, dass...
Ich muss jetzt konzentrieren.
Also, was sehe ich denn noch?
Wie gesagt, ich habe auch von Dart keinen Plan.
Also, ich sehe hier
Main. So, das ist wahrscheinlich...
Oh, guck mal, man kann direkt runnen.
Okay, das finde ich cool.
Und jetzt?
Startet das jetzt?
Oh.
Da ist es. Nice.
Max, Max, es ist kompiliert.
Ja, gut, das ist...
Ey, aber das ist die Standard-App. Wenn die nicht kompiliert...
Wir machen jetzt
einen BMI-Rechner, Leute.
Haha, das ist die beste
Standard-App. Wir machen einen BMI-Rechner.
Hahaha.
Ähm.
Dart DevTools
includes additional
tools for debugging and profiling.
Include a widget inspec...
Was?
What? Open.
Jetzt ist es weg.
Was? Was war das?
Widget?
Widget Inspector?
Was inspected der?
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Okay, da funktioniert nicht so ganz der Widget Inspector,
würde ich sagen.
Oh, nice.
Leute, ich darf die App nicht beenden mit dem normalen Shortcut.
Oh, die App ist gecrashed.
Ich glaube, wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
Monarch S ist kaputt.
Okay, beenden.
Jawohl, Terminator.
Mach kaputt.
Wie, Moment.
Warum ist es noch da?
Das soll...
Das soll weg?
Oh, jetzt habe ich es verschoben auf einen anderen Desktop
und jetzt ist es verschwunden.
Ist es jetzt noch da oder ist es weg?
Ich... Okay.
Okay, ich runne nochmal.
Das ist bestimmt noch gestartet,
jetzt irgendwie transparent.
Oder so.
Ah, nee, okay, passt.
Kann man das jetzt normal beenden?
Okay, okay, gut.
Also, passt.
Also, was sehe ich denn jetzt hier?
Irgendwie...
Das ist so ein Zwischending zwischen Java und...
und...
Attribut...
Ruby?
Nee.
So eine Swift...
So eine Swift-Java-Mischung oder so?
Ein bisschen...
Kobol.
Ja.
Genau.
Erinnert mich auf den ersten Blick an Kobol.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
This is the theme of your application.
Primary... Okay, was kann man jetzt noch machen?
Blue.
Dann kann man jetzt sagen...
Black.
Und dann kann man starten.
Oh, nee.
Das hat es kaputt gemacht, oder?
Warum hat es das kaputt gemacht?
Blue ist okay.
A black is broken.
Warum? Hä?
Run?
Hä? Oh, es ist gecrashed.
Leute.
Es ist gecrashed, oder?
Nee, doch nicht.
Es sah nur so aus.
Okay, klar.
Warum geht Blue...
Hä?
Warum geht Blue und Black nicht?
Ah, Moment. Black ist eine Color.
Und Blue ist eine...
Material Color.
Okay, das finde ich ja schon mal äußerst verwirrend.
Okay, Black gibt es nicht als Material Color.
Alles klar.
Okay, ich habe...
Keine Ahnung, warum aber...
Warum gibt es da 30?
30 verschiedene Colors.
Und alles im gleichen Color Objekt.
Okay, Deep Purple.
Starten.
So, das heißt, unser Button unten müsste jetzt lila sein.
Der Chat täuscht wieder vor Trigger zu sein.
Ach, guck mal.
Das ganze Team ist jetzt lila.
Laila.
Unser Lehrer in der Schule, bei dem wir das Fach IT Systeme hatten,
ihr könnt euch vorstellen, so geil war das nicht.
Wir haben im Prinzip nur ein bisschen mit Microsoft Office rumgewurstet.
Und du hast mal immer eine Eins gekriegt, wenn du lila reingemacht hast in das Dokument.
Dann hat er sich gefreut und ist rumgerannt und hat gesagt,
oh, Laila, Laila, Laila und hat dir eine Eins gegeben.
Weiß nicht, was mit dem Kerl los war, der war auf jeden Fall nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Und wir haben dort eines der schlimmsten Sachen überhaupt gemacht.
Microsoft Access.
97, nee, Quatsch.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich 97.
Ich glaube, wir haben wirklich Microsoft Access 97 gemacht.
Das kommt ungefähr hin.
Das hier.
Ja, das hier.
Du große Scheiße.
Ja, ja.
Keck, wait.
Gab es Access 95?
Boah.
Das war schon painstamping damals.
Alter.
Das war schon richtig painstamping.
Warum hat man eigentlich überhaupt Access verwendet?
Reiner Zufall.
Schon aus dem Start bis ungleich gesubbt.
So mag ich das.
So muss das sein.
Das ist Doppel-IQ-Steigerung für den Chat.
Okay, okay.
Also, ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich gucken, was ich hier sehe.
Also, ich sehe irgendein Main Widget.
Also, das ist wahrscheinlich mein Root-Element, vermute ich mal.
My App.
Das ist im Prinzip,
ist im Prinzip sowas wie Body bei HTML.
So.
Und hier sind so die Default, die Default Styling für die gesamte App.
So, und dann gibt es den Start von meiner App ist dann quasi My Homepage.
So, und was sehe ich jetzt hier?
My Homepage erbt von Stateful Widget.
Also, ich rate jetzt im Prinzip nur,
weil ich habe von Dart und Flutter keine Ahnung.
So, das hier sieht mir ein bisschen aus,
wie Constructor Chaining.
Also sprich,
also wenn, wenn,
was ist denn das da hinne dran?
Was ist das?
Das verstehe ich.
Also im Prinzip das hier
ruft den Constructor davon auf.
Das verstehe ich.
Aber was macht denn hier dieses,
ist das, ist das der,
ist das der normale Constructor, den man hier nur inline schreibt oder was?
Oder, nee.
Ach, das sind die Parameter, oder?
Kann das sein, was für Parameter man braucht,
dass man das instanzieren kann?
Aha, ok, verstehe.
Also ich sehe, ich muss mal ein Dart-Tutorial machen, glaube ich.
This is Homepage of your Appli...
It is Stateful, meaning...
State Object.
Final String Title.
Ok, kann ich da mehrere Sachen machen?
String keg w?
Lull? Geht das?
Nee, das geht nicht, weil das übergebe ich hier oben nicht.
Was ist, was macht ein Key an der Stelle?
Aber ich kann jetzt sagen,
required
this lull.
Und dann?
Achso, Moment.
Das geht ja nicht, das ist ja, ähm,
Custom Class, ok.
Alles klar, nice.
Ach, jetzt kann man das natürlich nicht instanzieren,
weil das hier aufgerufen wird, aber ich kann hier
wahrscheinlich das übergeben.
Ok, lull
kriegt jetzt empty string.
So.
Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Gucken wir mal, ob das auch startet jetzt.
Ja, das starten dauert aber
schon nervig lang, ne?
So, jetzt können wir den geilen Button pushen.
Wie kriegt man das eigentlich ohne
Debug gestartet?
Wir haben es doch vorhin gestartet mit "-d", ne?
Kann man das einfach ohne "-d starten, dann ist es
ohne Debug?
Ah, nee. Vielleicht eher Release?
Help?
Wow, 30 Milliarden Dinger.
Ach, "-d", ist device?
Nee.
Dann musst du ein Bild machen, ok. Flutter, Bild.
Flutter, Bild,
Linux.
Ok, das, also ich muss sagen,
das Kommandozeilentool gefällt mir.
Ah, du musst, ich muss nicht neu starten, das
reloadet.
Ah, das ist cool.
Das ist nice, das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
So, und wo liegt das Bild jetzt? Wahrscheinlich
irgendwo hier oben drüber in Builds? Nee.
In, achso, ich bin wieder rausgegangen.
In, Bild.
Linux.
x86
Release.
What the fuck, und wie starte ich das jetzt?
Flutter, but. What?
Wofür benutzt man Flutter?
Um, um, um grafische Anwendungen
zu machen. Wie startet man den Kram
jetzt? Bundle?
MyApp, aha.
MyApp.
Oh, das geht jetzt ja relativ zackig.
Das geht relativ zügig jetzt.
Fühlt sich auch gleich deutlich geschwinter an.
Jo.
Für welche Sprache? Dart, das ist ne eigene
Sprache. Wieso zeigt
dein LS so viele Infos an? Weil das
kein LS ist, sondern
das ist eigentlich EXA.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das
noch weiterentwickelt wird. Das ist, äh,
nen
Rust,
ein LS in Rust nachgebaut.
Ok, wird anscheinend
auch weiterentwickelt. Ist relativ beliebt
sogar auf GitHub. Ok, das heißt,
wir haben jetzt live reload. Moment,
jetzt müssen wir einfach gucken, wie groß ist denn so ne Flutter-App?
Was braucht
man überhaupt, um die Flutter-App laufen zu lassen?
Das komplette Verzeichnis
oder nur die App?
Ah, ne, das komplette Verzeichnis wahrscheinlich,
ne? Warum brauchen die
GTK? Also sprich,
wenn ich die App jetzt beispielsweise,
äh,
MyApp,
wenn ich die jetzt eins hochkopiere,
dann geht's
nimmer, hm? Ja.
Genau. Kann man
Flutter self-contained
Build? Geht das?
Äh, Flutter?
Ich hab noch nicht verstanden, für was
die jetzt genau... Ok,
anscheinend gibt's kein self-contained Build.
App-Images, ja
gut, das ist, ja, wär cool,
wenn's das komplett von aus könnte.
Google steht da ja drauf, machen sie mit Go
auch. Aber für was die jetzt
genau GTK verwenden, hab ich nicht
verstanden. Also, wahrscheinlich
um so Sachen zu machen, wie, äh,
Fenster erstellen und Mausklicks
mitbekommen und sowas.
So, wie
groß ist denn der Kram?
Da muss man Bundle?
55 MB, das geht.
Das ist in der heutigen Zeit durchaus in Ordnung.
Und wie viel RAM braucht so ne Flutter-App?
Äh, ich überleg grad.
Oh, wie hieß das nochmal?
Mit SMM konnte man gucken
und mit...
Egal, ich nehm irgendeinen GUI
Prozess Explorer oder so.
Na ja, mit Hardtop ist immer so ne Sache, wenn das Ding mehr
Threads hat. Ne, es gibt so,
es gibt, es gibt so ne SMM-Abwandlung,
die ist gar nicht so übel. Guck, weil hier siehst du
nicht, was das alles,
äh, MyApp.
128 MB
Web-Content.
Ja, ich mein,
128 MB, das geht, wenn's
nicht wirklich viel größer wird.
Also, 128
MB für ne, für ne Hallo World-App
ist natürlich relativ viel, aber ich mein, da ist ja auch
schon einiges geladen zum Rendern.
Die Frage ist, wie viel, wie schnell das
größer wird, wenn man da Sachen hinzufügt.
Ne, also ich
find 128 MB ist, ist schon in Ordnung.
Grade in der heutigen Zeit, wenn
du mal guckst, was so Elektronenscheiß braucht, wenn's gestartet
ist. Okay, also
so, okay, jetzt müssen wir die, die, die
Live-Reload-Geschichte ausprobieren.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also, wir können das starten und dann können wir die Farbe
ändern und das ändert live die Farbe,
oder wie? Jetzt bin ich ja mal
gespannt. Okay. Machen wir
Blue?
Ha! Boah!
Das ist ja nice!
Man muss das nicht neu
starten und er erkennt sofort die neuen
Settings. Ja, das
ist cool. POG!
Richtig
POG! Okay, sehr
schön. Okay, was sehe
ich sonst noch so? Constructor,
irgendwelche Class-Variablen
oder so. Override?
Das check ich nicht so genau.
Das ist sowas wie...
Ey gut, das ist
äh, wahrscheinlich
eine Methode aus StatefulWidget
überschrieben. Woher weiß ich
denn, was ich alles over...
overriden
kann? Ah, okay, anscheinend...
Ne, Moment. MyHomepageState
kann doch davon nix
sein? Äh...
Woher weiß
es, dass es MyHomepageState gibt?
Wo kommt denn MyHome... Ach, da unten drunter ist
MyHomepageState.
Ach so.
Warum was overridet er denn da?
Okay, das
habe ich noch nicht so genau gecheckt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich finde das mit Dart bis jetzt
gar nicht so schlimm. Ich habe halt keine Ahnung davon.
Build?
What the fuck?
Ach, das
ist jetzt das eigentliche Layout
oder was?
Moment, warum gibt es MyHomepage
und dann gibt es MyHomepageState
und
im State ist das Layout?
Warum ist
das Layout im State?
Okay...
Also, wenn ich da jetzt reinschreibe...
Cute...
Chat... Ah, ja, ja...
Dann steht... Aber das...
Also, ich muss sagen, das Live
Reloaden ist schon cool.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Macht er das hier automatisch? Ah,
das fügt er hier automatisch rein. Das finde ich cool.
Sowas könnten die, by the way, in HTML
auch machen. Zwischendrin, dass man
sieht, was was ist, an welcher Ebene.
FloatingActionButton,
das ist das Ding da unten.
Ach hier, Tooltip.
So, was hat das Ding noch?
Elevation.
Wie hervorgehoben der ist, oder was?
10?
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied vom ActionButton.
Hier, was auch immer.
FocusColor?
Okay, jetzt aktuell FocusColor nix.
FocusColor...
Color?
Oh.
Ne, was war das? Colors, ne?
Äh, FocusColor is gelb.
Vielleicht geht's da drüber?
Oder auch nicht.
Hm. Hover?
Ah, HoverColor.
Colors.
Jetzt aber.
Ah!
Oh, wenn man das
jetzt noch animieren könnte, wäre schon cool, ne?
Okay, jetzt haben wir
HugeColor geändert.
Allerwichtigste aller Zeiten.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich kann man Animations
nicht so einfach machen. ChildIcon.
Okay, da kann man verschiedene Sachen angeben, was man haben will.
Wahrscheinlich...
Ah, das sind so die StandardMaterialDesign
Icons, die man hier hat.
Gibt es eigentlich für Flutter
auch noch was anderes als MaterialDesign?
Also, könnte man
eine Flutter-Anwendung aussehen lassen, wie
Windows?
Oder ist das
alles MaterialDesign?
Weil irgendwo schreiben die doch hier
ReturnsMaterialApp
Kann man sagen?
ReturnMaterialApp
Gibt es sonst was für Apps?
App?
CupertinoApp?
Das sieht dann aus wie
Apple, oder wie?
Okay.
Lull?
Okay, da musst du mal rumgucken.
Flutter?
Okay, das ist BigBrain.
Der neue Ubuntu-Installer wird
in Flutter geschrieben, okay.
Warum auch nicht?
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal nicht,
wie ich mir das so gedacht habe.
Wir bleiben mal beim StandardDesign,
glaube.
Oh, wenn es gecrashed ist, ist es gecrashed, dann
reloadet es sich nicht mehr automatisch.
Okay, wenn man es schafft, dass die App
crasht, muss man neu starten.
Interessant.
Das ist ja auch gut, kann ich verstehen.
Was? Kann es starten, please?
Okay, also was gibt es denn
eigentlich? Material...
Wie heißt das Ding?
MaterialApp... App...
Da wollten sie nicht Apple schreiben.
Was gibt es denn da noch alles?
Gibt es auch Windows?
WindowsApp?
Ne, es gibt bloß die zwei, oder?
Ah, es gibt anscheinend nur die zwei.
Okay, naja.
Dann bleiben wir erstmal beim MaterialDesign.
Ich meine, man kann ja auch mit MaterialDesign
die Sachen nicht ganz so Android-mäßig
aussehen lassen.
Okay, also was haben wir jetzt sonst noch?
Was ich jetzt mal gucken will ist,
kann man... Wie füge ich jetzt hier
was neues ein? Also...
Widget, Text, Counter,
FloatingActionButton.
So, der Button ist hier.
Kann ich jetzt anstatt dem Button
hier nochmal... Sag mal, ich mach
da jetzt noch einen Button rein. Geht das?
Nope.
Okay.
Wie kriege ich da noch einen Button rein?
Column.
Ah, das hier ist die Column
und das ist quasi eine Variable.
Das heißt, ich kann das nicht zweimal machen.
Ja, ich... Wie gesagt...
Ach, ich will jetzt einfach nur ein bisschen rumspielen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie super...
Also, wie mache ich ein Textfeld? Okay, Flutter.
Textfeld.
Textfield. Bam.
Textfield. ObscureText.
Zack.
Ach, so einfach kann es gehen.
Sollte ich vielleicht einfach mal die
Default-App wegwerfen?
Was? XQC ist gebannt? Echt? Warum?
But why?
Oh.
Warum ist der schon wieder gebannt?
Ach, der wurde auf GTA gebannt.
Was haben wir denn gemacht?
Okay, das heißt, wir schmeißen jetzt mal die Default-App weg.
Moment.
Das geht ja noch weiter da unten.
Okay, das ist Big Brain.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Was soll...
Okay, so wahnsinnig intuitiv ist es jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich machen muss.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt was Schlechtes.
Ah, hier. Children.
Hier kann man Sachen reinschreiben, denke ich mal.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier noch mal
Text.
Kann man übrigens auch Doppelquoten?
Okay, das funktioniert.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Also hier kann ich jetzt noch was reinmachen.
Hier kann ich jetzt auch mal ein Textfeld
reinmachen.
Bam! Mein Textfeld ist am Start.
Huge Textfeld.
Hackerman.
Obscure Text.
False.
Excellent, excellent.
Aber es ist ganz schön
laggy. Es ist ganz schön
laggy, wenn du hier reinklickst.
Also gut
funktionieren ist, tut es nicht.
Klick, klick.
Ich habe jetzt schon fünf Mal rausgeklickt
und es geht nicht weg. Sollte nicht
der Text
entselected werden, wenn ich rausklicke?
Oder muss man das selbst machen?
Das liegt an Debug.
Und wenn ich hier
reinklicke, wird es auch nicht selected. Nur hier.
Ach, guck mal, wenn ich auf den Button
klicke. Ne, auf Button ist...
Nice Passwortliefer.
Ja.
Okay, das heißt, ich soll ein Bild machen.
Ist das dann besser?
Bild.
Linux.
Bilde.
Was würdest du für Android Apps empfehlen,
wenn man keine Website hat, zum in App
konvertieren?
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Ich habe noch nie
eine Android App gemacht.
Also ich, ganz ehrlich,
also mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt eine
Android App machen, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch eine iOS App
machen wollen. Und ich würde wahrscheinlich gucken,
dass ich irgendeine Ionic
Webseite bastle.
Oder einen
Hentai Viewer.
Ne, aber dann, ich würde wahrscheinlich gucken, dass ich irgendeine Ionic
Webseite oder so bastle.
Vue.js Webseite und dann konvertieren
zu irgendwas native mäßiges. Ich habe
keine Ahnung davon. Ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Okay, also Bild.
Linux.
Release.
Moment, da war es doch schon.
My App.
Oh, das ist die alte. Die hätte ich mal
löschen müssen. Flutter.
Ne, Bundle muss ich. Bundle.
Bundle My App.
Also man muss sagen,
das ist aber nice, dass das relativ schnell startet.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Okay, es ist nicht
mehr so laggy. Aber das mit
dem Fokus funktioniert immer noch nicht. Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich an mir.
Okay, also es ist auf jeden Fall
schon mal nicht so laggy wie vorher.
Ah doch.
Oh doch, das ist ganz schön laggy.
Hohoho.
Alter ist das laggy.
Boah, das verschluckt Tastenanschläge.
Okay, das ist noch nicht so gut.
So, gucken wir mal weiter. Gibt es den Webview?
Allerwichtigster.
Die wichtigen Sachen müssen wir mal abchecken.
Flutter Linux Webview.
Flutter
Webview. Aha, auf dem
Desktop schon mal nett.
Da ist kein eingebauter Webview.
Echt nicht?
Kann ich einfach sagen Web?
Web?
Widget oder so? Webview?
Ne.
Ist das vielleicht wegen
Emulation? Ja, es ist die Frage, wie
die das malen. Also, ich bin mir
immer noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie die Architektur ist.
Ich meine, die brauchen zwar GTK,
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich nur
ein GTK Reskin ist.
Ich vermute mal, dass sie GTK
verwenden für so Sachen wie
wie gesagt, Fenster öffnen, Fenster schließen,
Mausevents handeln und sonst was.
Ich denke mal, dass die
dass die eigentliche App
auch kein Chrome ist,
sondern, dass es wirklich einen
Tja, was auch immer
für eine darunter liegende Render-Geschichte
ist. OpenGL,
Vulkan,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
was da unten drunter ist.
X-Server Software Rendering, keine Ahnung.
Und dann malen die einfach
ihre Sachen ins Fenster rein.
Also, einfach in Anführungsstrichen.
Okay, einen Webview für Flutter Desktop
gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Das ist schon mal doof.
Skia, ja, das kann auch sein, ja.
Aber das ist die Frage, was benutzt man?
Und die?
Weil irgendwie muss die auf die Grafikkarte, das Zeug.
Chainlore nebenbei
Boopcam schauen,
vermute ich jetzt mal.
Weiß ich nicht. Kann man das aufmachen? Ist das safe?
Ich will wissen, was der Chainlore sich da anguckt.
What the fuck?
Lol, was ist hier los?
Sind wir auf...
Wie heißt das?
Nicht Pornhub.
Das Ding noch mal für die Webcams.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Lol, Alter.
Chat repaid, genau.
Lol.
Was geht hier eigentlich ab auf Twitch
mittlerweile?
Soll ich das auch mal machen?
Chat? Soll ich das auch machen?
Soll ich auch mal die Hose halb runterziehen
und mich filmen dabei?
Genau. Wenn ich... Ey, Leute.
Ohne Scheiß. Wetten, wetten.
Ich würde gebannt werden.
Ich mach den Arsch in die Kamera halt.
Onlyfans, man.
Oh man.
Leute, ich fürchte, dass mit Flutter wird nicht so
wirklich was, weil
ich müsste erstmal ein bisschen Dart lernen.
Ich tu mir unglaublich schwer, hier durch
zu blicken, was hier gerade eigentlich abgeht.
Ein Webview gibt's
anscheinend auch nicht. Okay.
Chainlore kennt sich aus.
Aber wir müssen jetzt hier nicht übertreiben.
Man kann ja auf
die jeweiligen Channels gehen, wenn man das gerne sieht.
Leute, ich... Leute, also...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich hab mir das jetzt ein bisschen easier vorgestellt.
Ich dachte mir, das sieht aus wie vielleicht irgendwie
wie normale UI-Frameworks
von der Programmiersprache, die man halt
irgendwie versteht. Ich hab legit
absolut
keinen Schimmer, was hier sich tut gerade.
Ich muss mir mal ein Dart-Tutorial
off-stream angucken. Das wird sonst nix.
So wie...
Ups.
SVGA Surface Destroy.
Lösch mal die Kommentare, dann sieht's weniger
Plaut aus. Das ist wohl wahr,
aber dann hab ich ja noch weniger Ahnung, was hier passiert.
Es sieht auch
nicht schlecht aus. Also es ist auf jeden Fall nichts,
was mich jetzt irgendwie an
eklige Auswüchse von C++ erinnert
oder so. Das sieht eigentlich relativ clean
aus und man kann das auch gut lesen.
Das Problem ist, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer,
wie was zusammenhängt. Das ist mein
hauptsächliches Problem.
Oh, verstehe.
Flutter-Tutorial von
NetNinja. Den hab ich schon öfters mal
geguckt. Das ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Also eine Sache, die ich wirklich gut
finde, wo sich noch mehr
UI-Frameworks was von abschneiden könnten, die halt
nicht komplett browser-based sind,
da geht es ja zum größten Teil schon,
ist die Live-Reload-Geschichte.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall ne coole
Sache, ne? Also wenn man das hier
offen hat und sagt jetzt hier, keine Ahnung, man möchte die ganze
Application auf einmal in yellow haben
und speichert,
und das ganze Ding wird yellow. Das ist auf jeden Fall
äußerst nice.
Wie würde ich denn jetzt hier in das Passwort-Feld überhaupt was
reinschreiben?
Äh, Skia Flutter benutzt OpenGL, OpenGL ES,
Vulkan und mehr. Okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Und PDF. Was zum Teufel ist
PDF? Also das hat
bestimmt nichts mit PDF zu tun, was ich mir unter
PDF vorstelle.
Okay, also ich vermute mal, wenn ich hier was reinschreiben
will, dann bräuchte ich so ne Art
Data Binding, ne?
Wie krieg ich in das
Textfeld den Text rein und
raus? Reading
Values. What?
OnPress?
You typed value?
Content?
Ne, Moment. Child Text
Field?
Wow, das ist echt next level shit,
äh, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das treibt, äh.
Text Field Controller?
Unsubmitted?
Okay, unsubmitted macht man
inline irgendwie
Text oder so?
Also sprich,
unsubmitted und dann hier irgendwie so ne
Okay.
Alert?
Alert Dialog?
Ne.
Unreturned
die Dinger dann? Boah, das ist
übelst
Awage?
Das ist übelst
undurchsichtig.
Kann das dann irgendwas im Terminal ausgeben?
Console? Ne.
Du kannst das in der Variable speichern.
Ah, sprich, also,
äh, Moment, wo ist mein Counter?
Wo ist mein Counter? Counter? Dollar?
Counter?
Context?
Wo ist die Variable für den Counter?
Counter?
Moment, wo kommt das her?
Ach, das kommt aus dem
My Homepage State.
Das haben wir da oben. Aha.
Okay.
Also,
könnte ich jetzt quasi, wenn ich in das Text
Feed was eingebe,
wir machen jetzt mal nicht den Counter, wir machen jetzt mal
was eigenes, irgendwie, äh,
String.
Bloop.
Wie sowas.
Und dann
kann ich hier im
Moment, wo ist denn hier überhaupt was gewesen?
Unsubmitted. Kann ich jetzt sagen
This. Das mag ich übrigens schon mal.
Ich, ich, ich finde das ja immer
Achso, ne.
Tell you.
Muss man eigentlich am Ende
Semikolon machen oder nicht?
Ja, muss man.
SetState nicht vergessen. Was zum?
So?
Nee, oder?
Ich hab kein, kein, absolut
keine Ahnung.
Okay. Kann ich jetzt an der Stelle
sagen, ich will,
ich will meine Bloop-Variable haben?
Geht das? Okay, so einfach
schon mal nicht.
IncrementCounter.
Ja.
Achso.
Ah.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, also die stehen auf diese
Geschichte mit Underscore für private
Sachen. Find ich eigentlich okay.
Bin ich eigentlich auch so gewohnt.
Okay. Okay, jetzt.
Aha. So, und jetzt kann ich hier unten
sagen Bloop.
Ha. Nee. Ah.
Ich muss Enter drücken.
Keck. Wait.
Ach, man muss Underscore machen, oder wie?
Okay, es, okay, wenn
es Unsubmitted gibt, gibt's auch bestimmt
On, OnChanged,
OnChanged.
Das ist auch nice. Jetzt krieg ich's beim Tippen.
Guckt. Bam.
Poggers. P
Orge
Errs.
Excellent.
So mag ich das.
Okay.
Einfach rausgehen und
und es ist, es ist schon
relativ laggy, muss man sagen.
Das könnte aber auch an der VM liegen, aber
so eine einfache Sache muss in der VM
auch schon gut funktionieren, ne?
Wie soll sonst was, was
was Komplexeres funktionieren?
Hast du schon mal in Proxmox gearbeitet?
Ich, wir haben's hier schon ausprobiert.
Ja, es ist, ist ganz nett, aber
ich, ich werd's nicht einsetzen.
Ich
hab da lieber kein GUI dazwischen.
Ich, ich mag meinen laggischen
Ubuntu-Server.
Paar Containers drauf und eine
VM, fertig.
Ich find das super, um das Layout zu testen.
Meinst du jetzt meine VM wäre VM oder die Flutter
VM? Sir
Old Crowd.
Eigentlich schon für den Sub zwei Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Aber ich hab, ich hab ein Bild gemacht.
Ich hab ein Bild gemacht, das war jetzt auch
nicht so super
snappy, ja, aber
schon auf jeden Fall besser als das hier.
Okay, nice.
Das, das, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an JavaScript-Zeug.
Gibt
es eigentlich sonst noch irgendwas, was Dart verwendet?
Außer, außer
eben, dass das so die, die hauseigene
Länge, warum haben die eigentlich
für Flutter Dart verwendet? Jetzt mal
ganz im Ernst, weil das bedeutet
doch im Endeffekt auch, du kannst keinerlei
schon existierende Libraries verwenden.
Kannst du versuchen, links und rechts
vom, ah, das ist ne gute Idee. Musst du mal
gucken, wie das geht.
Äh, Border? Nein.
Okay, Textfield.
Oder Margin?
Nein.
Äh, wir googeln einfach.
Flutter Textfield
Margin.
Padding?
Geht's beides nicht.
Okay, okay.
So. Spacing.
Add Padding.
Was?
Alt Enter?
What the fuck?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ach, Android Studio.
Ach ja, also.
Child Text Style.
Ah, da kann man noch ein Style
dazu angeben hier.
Style.
Hier, Style.
Da
vielleicht.
Style. Ah, Style.
Okay, ist größer. Leute, habt ihr gesehen,
es ist größer geworden. Das hat prinzipiell funktioniert.
Margin.
Padding.
Okay, was?
Ah, Moment, das ist ja nur Textstyle.
Das ist ja nur Textstyle.
Ich will ja kein Textstyle. Ich brauch irgendwie...
Okay, wie geht das jetzt?
Background. Background Color.
Spacing?
Hab ich da was von Spacing gesehen?
Okay, das ist nur für Text.
Das brauchen wir net.
Padding. What?
Padding.
Wrap das Textfield. Okay, das heißt
Padding. Okay.
Also sag mal Padding, keine Ahnung, 30.
Und jetzt sag ich Child wahrscheinlich, ne?
Child. Und Child
kommt dann das Textfield rein.
Okay, was gibt's bei Padding dann für...
Gibt's da ne Zahl, oder?
Wow. Ah, oben, unten, links,
rechts. Ah!
Guck mal hier.
Das ist doch relativ gut durchdacht, muss ich
sagen. All.
All 20.
Hey, das ist...
Ja, das ist doch eigentlich ganz
nett. Was wird denn geprockt?
Gar nichts. Ich guck's mir einfach nur an.
Ich guck mir das einfach
nur ein bisschen an. Ich hab damit noch nie was gemacht.
Okay, aber die Performance...
Kann ich das jetzt eigentlich
bilden von Linux aus für Windows?
Wait a minute. Enable.
Enable.
Windows.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Wine.
Ey, wenn das in Wine läuft...
Okay, Build. Windows.
Ah, Build Windows
only supported on Windows
Most. Okay, das ist
verständlich. Auf Windows
will ich's mir jetzt grad nicht installieren.
Okay, also.
So, wie krieg ich das jetzt oben
aligned? Das ist das nächste.
Das ist ja alles in der Mitte.
Also, Child Column.
Da brauch ich jetzt wahrscheinlich...
Ah, Body Center. Guck mal.
Gibt's da so viel? Top, Center.
Top ist Standard? Einfach nur Top? Nee, oder?
Also, ich kann
theoretisch das Center dann einfach weg...
Das Child einfach wegmachen.
Guck mal, der löscht das manchmal. Guck mal.
Der erkennt meine Backspace-Taste nicht.
Lol, weh. Was ist denn das?
Der erkennt meine Backspace nicht.
Okay, das ist... Okay.
Der erkennt weder Pfeiltasten
vorwärts und rückwärts erkennt er.
Aber... Hä? Okay, das ist
verbuggt.
Boogie. Jetzt geht's.
So, das heißt jetzt auch nicht
Passwort, sondern
kekwe-input.
Kekwe-input-Decoration.
Aber das ist trotzdem... Also, das finde ich ist
eine coole Sache, wie sie das hier gelöst haben mit dem Styling.
So, wie...
Aligne ich das denn jetzt oben?
Ach, hier.
Top, Center, End.
Also, Start.
Warum genau war das jetzt
Center Aligned?
So, das ist ein bisschen Flexbox Light jetzt quasi.
Demo, Homepage.
Cute Chat
App.
So, wir brauchen ein Image.
Wir brauchen unbedingt
ein Image. Wie macht man ein Image?
Flutter-Image.
Wir brauchen Ayaya-Image.
What?
Hier, Image.
Also sprich, wir machen jetzt hier oben
hier unten drunter unter
dem Textfeld
hier ist das Textfeld zu Ende, machen wir
ein Image. Moment.
Hier.
Ah, yes.
Unable to load Asset.
Ja klar, haben wir ja auch nicht.
So, wo macht man die Assets jetzt hin?
Bild.
Flutter-Assets.
Ah, per Datei. Ich kann aber einfach den Link
benutzen, ne?
Immer mal das, was der Chainlord gerade gepostet hat.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt von dem
Wikipedia-Bild, was massig
Aufrufe hatte, weil irgendeine indische App
das drinne hatte?
Ah, Moment, das ist ein Asset-Image.
Das will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich will einfach nur Image vom Url oder so.
Image.
Network.
Aha.
Okay, das ist jetzt schon mal merkwürdig.
Manchmal braucht man
ein eigenes Objekt und jetzt muss man irgendwie
Hä?
So.
Da ist wahrscheinlich Url drinne oder sowas, hä?
Url.
Oh Mensch.
Image. Network. Flutter.
Google. Beste.
Display-Image vom Internet.
Ah, yes. Im Prinzip
einfach so. Wahrscheinlich
einfach, einfach den da.
Guck mal.
Ah, verstehe. Okay, sehr gut.
Bam! Nice.
QChat.
QQ-Input.
Hier, das funktioniert schon mal.
Da brauchen wir jetzt natürlich die passende
Farbe für.
Blau passt da nicht. Was für eine Farbe?
Purple?
Ah.
Äh, was heißt denn, was heißt denn Rosa?
Was ist denn Rosa?
Magenta?
Pink?
Ah, yes.
Die Magenta-DNA.
So ist es doch nice.
Qt-App.
Das ist einfach nur die Qt.
Ups. Die Qt-App.
So.
Okay, nice.
Okay, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns der Sache.
Können wir gleich im App-Store hochladen?
Stadia-Logo, please.
Warum willst du dir so einen Kack angucken?
Ach, du meinst in die App?
Nee. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay, der Counter macht hier nichts mehr unten.
Die Floating-Action-Buttons
können wir eigentlich wegmachen.
Ja, so. Viel bessere Qt-App.
Exzellente Qt-App.
So, was könnte
denn die Qt-App
jetzt Tolles machen?
Sound abspielen. Kann Flutter?
Kann das ein Sound abspielen?
Nee, BMI rechne nicht, wir machen die Qt-App.
Ich wollte eigentlich
einen Ayaya-Button machen, genau.
Eigentlich wollte ich einen Ayaya-Button machen.
Wenn man hier unten draufklickt,
dann gibt es einen Sound.
Aber es gibt anscheinend keinen
Audio-Player.
Ich glaube, ich habe überhaupt,
ich habe hier überhaupt keine,
ich habe überhaupt keine Soundcard hier drin,
die funktioniert.
Was ist denn das für ein Framework,
ein Mobile-Framework?
Äh, wie hieß das Ding, was man für
ALSA-Mixer nochmal installieren muss?
Ähm, ALSA-Tools
oder sowas?
ALSA-Utils 8.
So, erstmal gucken, ob wir überhaupt
Sound in der VM abspielen können.
Master, PCM.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Max-FPD, alles klar.
So, mal gucken, ob der jetzt meine Videos abspielt.
Nee, ALSA direkt.
Bam. Hört ihr irgendwas?
Ich höre nichts.
Aber ich glaube, Chrome, Chrome-
kann ALSA direkt ohne Puls-Audio.
Hallo?
Okay, wait.
Alter, wir gucken uns so eine Kacke an.
Select Soundcard.
Ja, okay, also.
ALSA-Test.
ALSA-Test, da gibt es doch irgendwas.
Äh, nicht ALSA.
Da kann man doch Sound up.
Speaker-Test war es.
Speaker-Test.
Okay,
geht nicht.
Doch, ich habe eigentlich eine Soundkarte drinnen,
aber
die scheinen nicht
zu funktionieren.
Das ist meine gecrashte Flutter-App vom Anfang,
die ist immer noch da, Leute.
Sie lebt noch.
Ach, Leute, wisst ihr, was auch sein kann?
Dass im Mixer der Sound aus ist für die VM.
Okay, Leute,
ich kriege jetzt in der VM
keinen Sound zum Laufen.
Kann man vergessen, mit dem
Ayaya-Button.
Ich kriege kein Puls-Audio jetzt.
Aber, zumal
Puls-Audio nichts bringt,
der Speaker-Test mit ALSA-Direct müsste
auf jeden Fall funktionieren.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, ich habe volle Pulle auf.
Ich kann nochmal alles hoch machen,
aber das wird es nicht bringen.
Ach, wisst ihr, was sein kann?
Dass es die falsche Soundkarte benutzt.
Nee.
Nee, nee, ich habe nichts wegen Konsolen-Beep entfernt.
Glaubt nicht.
Dann würde er ja auch jetzt auch meckern.
Okay, das
kriege ich jetzt nicht gebacken.
Wundert mich, dass es so kompliziert ist, weil ich habe in meiner
anderen VM habe ich, also die, die ich sonst
verwende, wenn ich nicht am streamen
bin, habe ich das eingerichtet und das war eigentlich
relativ easy.
Warte mal.
Ist denn Windows wenigstens der Meinung, dass
es playt? Nee.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Dann bleiben wir bei der Qt-App ohne
Sound.
Okay, den Button können wir jetzt zunächst gebrauchen.
Chat-Set.
Ja, da kann ich nichts machen, wenn der Chat-Set ist.
Der Chat kann mir einfach sagen, weil ich noch
installieren muss, dass es funktioniert.
Der will die VM gerebootet haben.
Nee.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich bin mir auch nicht mehr sicher, was man machen musste,
dass es geht. Eigentlich reicht das.
Brauchst du den
Alsa-Mixer, machst Sound hoch, ich mache die Sound-Design
wieder aus, falls das hier...
Er hat ja auch prinzipiell die
Soundkarte erkannt.
Mach use default Soundkarte.
Ich hatte doch am Anfang default Soundkarte.
Ihr wollt ernsthaft, dass ich
reboote?
Ich spreche kein Deutsch, aber ich schau mich den Stream an.
Nice.
Excellent.
Okay, ihr wollt rebooted haben, na dann.
Wenn der Chat
das will, wollen wir mal nicht so sein.
Power off.
Ich muss nicht nur
rebooten, ich muss ausschalten.
So, jetzt.
Nee, wir machen keine Wette jetzt.
Gucken wir mal.
Wisst ihr, was richtig
Sättge ist, Leute?
Richtig massive Sättge?
Dass morgen wieder Dienstag ist
und wir alle arbeiten gehen müssen.
Das ist richtig Sättge.
Nee, Leute, der Speaker-Test geht
nicht. Keine Chance.
Wow.
Der Speaker-Test testet.
Links.
Rechts.
Also können wir doch
wieder playen.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Alter, warum ist denn mein...
Alter, wie fett ist denn mein Firefox gerade?
Excellent reboot.
Richtiger Mist für die Leute, die nicht im Homeoffice sind.
Können rumruschen.
Also bei uns hat es geschneit, aber es ist wieder
wieder alles weg.
Weiß nicht, wie ist es bei dir?
Okay, excellent.
Qt-App muss wieder gestartet werden.
Da können wir jetzt auch gleich mal lernen,
wie man Dependencies
hinzufügt.
Massive Schnee.
Ernsthaft? Wo kommst du her?
Bestimmt aus der Schweiz in den Bergen
irgendwo.
Sad-Sommer-Reifen-Users.
Ihr wisst, was ich vor zwei Tagen getauscht habe, oder?
Am Auto.
In weiser Voraussicht.
Das ist das, wo ich im Stream abgehauen bin zwischendurch.
Aber ich fahr mit meinem Auto eh nicht.
Wo kommt die Mario-Musik her?
Da, wo auch
der ICQ-Sound herkommt.
Aus deinem
Lautsprecher.
Painstamp-Witz, ich weiß.
Hier, Playlist.
Playlist.
So, also wie geht es jetzt mit dem Soundplayer?
Hier, Flutter-Audioplayer.
Android, iOS,
MacOS, Web.
Alter, was ein Sucker-Player.
Der kann kein Linux.
Audio.
Hast du einen Windows-Notification-Sound
auf dem Board? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wenn ich euch trollen will,
wenn ich euch trollen will,
wenn ich euch trollen will, dann mache ich das hier.
Das ist fies.
Das ist echt fies.
Ich gucke gerade echt
nach links. FBI-Open-Up.
Gibt es irgendein Paket, was auf
Linux Audio abspielen kann?
Flutter. Android, iOS,
MacOS, Web.
Flutter-Sound, Android, iOS, Web.
Kann man das filtern?
Ich möchte
es gerne...
das filtern nach was unterstützt wird geht das anscheinend nicht die wichtigste funktion ist
wieder nicht dabei oder wie ich will einfach nur ein linux packages ich kann ja plattform
linux machen audio ok was auch immer ich da jetzt gemacht habe es funktioniert fügt mal
bei der material ab und noch sieben mode dark hinzu auch das ist eine gute idee das machen
wir so warum auto komplete das nicht ach so so sollte denn ich jetzt eigentlich dunkel werden
funktioniert nicht problem system reload immer stimmt vielleicht muss ein komplett
reloaden oder hier drunter okay das funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert nicht mal eine frage bezüglich vm linux möchte gern auch beim entwickeln mit
linux als us arbeiten kann ich dir nur empfehlen aber standardisierte hardware als vm sowohl mit
proxmox vmware und hyper-v wie nicht wirklich performance gelaufen stelle ich mich also ich
habe das unter vmware es ist die frage was du für eine für eine grafische oder was für desktop
environment verändert hast also gnome funktioniert finde ich nicht generell nicht gut
in der vm und in theme data brightness die brightness ist dark excellent dark theme
also gnome ist nicht so gut also alles was sich auf 3d beschleuniger und grafikkarte im rechner
verlässt ist in der vm jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig voll die meiste performance also was du machen kannst
irgendwie die die mate verwenden oder so was was halt nicht so sehr auf grafikkarte angewiesen ist
ich persönlich stehe ja total auf i3 und du siehst hier i3 kannst du dich nicht beschweren die drei ist
ist pockers schnell wunderbar ich kann ja auch irgendeine idee starten oder irgendwie noch ein
editor aufmachen oder so das lädt bei mir genau meine hat expired rider ist genauso lahm wie bei
mir auf den preischampistik
da. Guck mal. Ist genauso
lahm wie auf dem Host. Das Ding ist halt
nicht schnell.
Kann ich alles machen.
Ich kann auch für die coolen Effekte, kann ich auch
GLX Gears starten.
Huge Graphics, ich weiß.
Noch nie gesehen vorher.
Nicht
Kogas. Dreht sich falsch rum.
Wobei, ne, eins dreht sich richtig rum.
Ne, ich mag
DWM auch nicht. Ich finde das,
also, man kann es mit Minimalismus
auch total übertreiben.
Wie viel FPS?
Ja, anscheinend 60.
60 im Fullscreen.
Man muss, glaube ich,
man muss doch V-Sync ausschalten,
irgendwie, ne.
Dass das funktioniert.
Oder macht es das standardmäßig?
Disable V-Sync.
Was für ein Ding.
Ah, yes.
Jetzt ist er schneller. Guck mal, noch viel flüssiger.
6.216
FPS. Huge Kogas.
Hyper
Kogas.
Was hat dein Host-System für Specs?
Ähm, das sind 8700K,
16G RAM
und eine 1080Ti.
Aber die Grafikkarte macht es wirklich nicht aus in der VM.
Ein paar Sachen gehen halt in der VM
nicht gut. Zum Beispiel 4K-YouTube-Videos
gucken, weil die eben
keine Grafikkarten-Decoder
verwenden können. Ich verwende übrigens
auch das ein oder andere Sackless-Tool,
zum Beispiel S-Log.
Wer sich jetzt wundert, was passiert ist,
das Ding hat den Bildschirm gesperrt.
Und das ist halt
ein Bildschirm-Locker, der nichts
kann, außer Bildschirm locken und entlocken.
Aber
so ein paar Sachen verwende ich von denen
auch. Die VM,
äh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Muss ich mal kurz
gucken, was habe ich in der VM gegeben.
4 CPU-Kerne,
was ich nicht wirklich
brauche, aber besser haben als
brauchen. Und 16G RAM,
Bäm. Moment, habe ich
vielleicht sogar 32G in meinem Rechner
drin? Habe ich euch mitgebracht?
Wisst ihr das hier?
Oh, ich habe 32G.
Ich habe 32G RAM.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Wer kann nie genug RAM haben?
Ja, ob 16 oder 32G. 32G
habe ich auch aufgerüstet. Ich hatte am Anfang nur 16.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, 16 ist viel zu wenig.
Ich brauche 32, jetzt wo RAM so billig ist.
Leute, wir haben hier noch nichts
gefunden, wo man Audio unter Linux
abspielen kann.
Seht ihr mal? Das ist das Problem
jetzt an Flutter und Dart.
Du kannst halt keine bestehenden
Libraries verwenden.
Was, was
eigentlich
ziemlich suckt, ne?
Weil ich mein, ernsthaft, was weiß ich,
wie man unter Linux den Sound von Hand abspielt?
Ich meine, ich kann EXEC machen.
EXEC, Command,
Flutter.
Packages, Flutter, Sound.
Nee, das
Honigspray, guck mal.
Da steht doch schon ganz oben
Flutter, Android,
iOS, Web.
Webgit, sollte es auch auf Linux gehen?
Ah, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Soll ich das mal ausprobieren, ja?
Probier mal aus.
Flutter, Sound.
Wenn der Chat das sagt.
Nein, nein, nein, Spaß.
Das geht im Leben nicht unter Linux.
Das geht im Leben
nicht unter Linux.
Das können wir vergessen.
Wir machen ein EXEC.
Eben hat doch einer einen
Ayaya MP3 gepostet, oder?
Ja.
Das brauche ich.
So, mal.
Play, das da.
OK, excelent.
Audio play.
Was kann ich mit dem Kram aufspielt.
Okay, ich spiele.
Ich ich spiele so selten Audio,
gedrohnt ab.
Okay, EFF Play geht immer.
EFF Play geht immer das ganze jetzt
noch hin, EFF Play
hin.
ff play audio no window what the fuck no exit no display auto exit no display
exzellent so brauchen wir das so das heißt wenn wir auf den button drücken
wenn man auf den button drücken on pressed floating action button
naja er gehackt über die mp3 ja ich dachte es mir schon ich dachte es mir
schon chat chat ist schon schon eingeloggt oder weil geht auch unter
linux kann kein ding on press das brauner on press ok on press so also
flatter exe command process run import package das ist moment moment da ist
doch bitte
da ist doch bitte da ist doch bitte da ist doch bitte da ist doch bitte da ist
da gibt's doch bestimmt was eingebautes oder das system command.io make process
import.io ok machen wir import package package jetzt was dat ok da bin ich zu
nur mich für wie funktioniert das jetzt dat i o flutter import habe ich doch gemacht
das ist doch positiv das ist so das bilang nach einfach so konzipiert
gözgeblasen und man sagt gibt's nicht die was auch immer brokers start
gut das an sie im prinzipial funktioniert browser start okay das
funktioniert es funktioniert also ff play also fflyal ich würde wahrscheinlich kompletter fahrt This must be tested. User bin ffl. Claire Umsatz
Und dann, das nennen wir mal um
Ayaya.mp3
So, und hier
So, und jetzt
Playen wir
Ayaya.mp3
Äh
Was ist das Problem?
Ayaya
Hä?
Max, Ayaya.mp3
Does not contain any stream
Ach, FFPlay
FFPlay
Okay, okay, fast, fast
Ich muss noch Argumente andingsen
Autoexit
So
Hahaha
CuteApp ist am Start, Alter
Okay, man darf nicht zu oft klicken
Aber es funktioniert
Das als Wecker
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, also davon bist du auf jeden Fall wach
Kannst du den Sound auch
Abspielen, wenn du aufs Bild drückst?
Wenn es einen OnClick
Wenn es einen OnClick hat
Muss man mal gucken
Hat das einen OnClick?
Klick
On
Press
Hm
Flutter
OnClick
Image
Das Bild in einen Button rappen
Gesture Detector
Aber ein Button sieht wahrscheinlich dumm aus, oder?
Einen einfachen Button gibt es gar nicht, ne?
Na komm, ich nehme
Gesture
Gesture Detector
Alter!
Pli...
Was ist das für ein Trotz?
Gebadet, ja
Aber sag mal ernsthaft
Das ist doch irgendwann fünf Seiten
tief genestet, oder?
Das erkennst du doch dann gar nicht mehr
Okay
So, und jetzt kann man hier sagen
OnClick
OnPress
Ah, OnLongPress
Gibt sich einfach
OnPress
OnTap
Das ist ja
Mobile, okay
OnTap
Das da brauchen wir
Nice
Funktioniert
So, die Qt-App ist finished, würde ich sagen
OnPrem
OnPrem Flutter
Das ist, also
Wir sind nicht OnPrem
Wir sind eindeutig in der Cloud, ja?
Wir verwenden irgendwelche hardcoded Links zu Google
Okay
Ich hab
Heute hab ich was gelernt, ja?
Okay, jetzt machen wir mal ein Bild davon
Flutter, Kekwe
MyAppBuild
Ach Mist
Jetzt
Nee, Moment, das stimmt nicht
Ich hätte das an meine Bash-RC anhängen sollen
Aber ich brauch's wahrscheinlich nicht so oft
Max, was machst du?
Die App, die kommt jetzt direkt in PlayStore
Was kostet, was kostet ein Google
Was kostet ein PlayStore-Account?
Wichtigste App überhaupt
Die Qt-App
25 Euro, das ist ja nix?
Apple bezahlt's, glaub ich, über 100 Euro im Jahr
Na gut, deswegen sind die Apple-AppStore-Apps im Durchschnitt auch besser
Und nicht ganz so viel Müll drin
Aber auch viel Müll
Leute, die geht ja gar nicht
Die App funktioniert ja nur auf dem Desktop, wenn man FFmpeg installiert hat
Sonst kann er doch nichts abspielen
Ich will doch nicht wirklich
Chat, ich will doch nicht wirklich einen PlayStore-Eintrag für die App jetzt machen
Lasst euch doch nicht so gebeten, Alter
Ich mach das dafür, Alter
Das ist immer ernsthaft
Okay, guck mal
Native
Native Qt-App am Start
Und wenn man drauf drückt, spielt's nen Sound ab
Gibt es noch diese IamRich-App
Mit dem Diamant
Die nix konnte, außer rich zu sein
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Ich laden die nicht hoch, what the fuck
Windows
Windows, auf Windows-Apps gab's das auch
Auf Windows-Apps gab's das auch
Gibt's nicht mehr, oder was?
IamRichLE, ey
Und platzen billiger Taschenrechner
Oh, ist das schlecht
Ist das schlecht
Und die Leute nehmen das auch noch ernst
Oh, ist das schlecht, Alter
Gibt's IamRich-App
Gibt's die wenigstens auch noch für Android
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt die IamRich-App gekauft
Äh, für...
Google Phone, äh, nicht Google, äh
Microsoft Windows Phone
Kostet?
Kostet? Wie viel kostet's denn?
Ist egal dabei
Kann es sein, dass Google, dass Google
Keine Preise mehr dahin schreibt?
Außer man ist am Handy?
Naja, ich akzeptiere alles
Oh man, was ein Schwachsinn
Na gut, Leute, wir haben's geschafft
Wir haben die Qt-App am Start
Was macht die App?
Die hat nen Button
Einschreiben
Und es macht nen Sound, wenn man draufklickt
Beste App
Und dafür ist das Ganze
Jetzt haltet euch mal fest
Ups
Und dafür ist die App nur
56 MB groß
Und braucht nur
Wollen wir mal kurz hier
Wollen wir mal kurz alles zu
Was noch auf war
Braucht nur
Öh
Nur 36 MB
RAM
Das geht doch
Voll klar
Das geht doch voll klar
Elektron hat jetzt erstmal
54 MB RAM gefressen
Und, und
15 Chromium Threads gestartet
Oh guck mal
Der mag nicht so viele Sachen starten
Beste App überhaupt
Jetzt, es wird Zeit, Leute
Ich würd sagen
Zeit Startup zu gründen, oder?
Oh guck mal, die gibt den RAM nicht wieder frei
Wieso ist das weniger?
Weil das letzte Mal war es Debug, jetzt ist es das richtige Bild
Ayaya as a Service
Ja, ich find auch
Qt Chat Limited
Was haltet ihr davon?
Qt Chat Ltd
Wie?
Das gibt's schon?
Qt Chat?
Moment, warum gibt es so viele Projekte
Gibt's auf GitHub was, was Qt Chat heißt?
Qt Chat
What the
Fuck
Was auch?
Qt Chat hat keine Issues
Ja, kann ich verstehen
I, Java
Ups
Leute, ich bin begeistert
Meine erste Flutter App, ist sie nicht geil?
Exquisite
Ja, richtige
Also für die erste Flutter App hier
Ich fass es nicht
Meine erste Flutter App
Die Qt App
Eigentlich richtig sinnlos
Ja, nice
Okay Chat, wir machen mal kurz hier den
Genug Flutter gebastelt für heute
Das neue Instagram
Instagram
Wer will Instagram?
Neue Clubhouse
Instagram ist schon out
Doshouse, genau
Stimmt, das gibt's ja schon
Wobei, es muss eigentlich
Meinem Alter angemessen sein
Und meinem Alter angemessen wäre es eher
Das nächste Facebook
Weil die Leute in meinem Alter sind alle auf Facebook
Und fühlen sich richtig geil
Und machen da Boomer Witze
Ich bin nicht Cloud Native
Wenn ich nicht Instagram sag
Ich sag ja auch schon
Jubantu und Amazon
Das sollte eigentlich reichen
Und Jira und Shit
Und Shit
Facebook
Ich kann's nicht verstehen
Weil ich hab nie Facebook verwendet
Doch wobei
Ich hab ne Max FPS Seite auf Facebook
Weil die Leute früher Facebook verwendet haben
Aber
Ich hab da seit 3 Jahren nix mehr gepostet
Was ist das?
Hahaha
Das ist so keine
Das ist wo ich mich über
Die
Die Gamescom Aktion
Lustig gemacht hab
Und erst mal
Häftling gepostet
Fingerleak
Auf Facebook
Hahaha
Das hat deutlich
Mehr Likes
Das stimmt hier einfach nicht
Das hatte 800 oder sonst was
Hier guck mal
Das
Gibt's den noch?
Schon eine Weile
Nix mehr gehört
Ja
Ich werd jetzt auch Computerfutzi
300 Leute haben einfach den Facebook Account gelöscht
Das oder es war nicht 800
Ist ja auch egal
Facebook juckt mich
Also ich muss sagen Facebook hab ich nur gemacht
Weil die Leute es damals hatten
Nicht weil ich Facebook irgendwie gut fand
Übrigens auf Facebook steht eine Sache
Die stimmt überhaupt nicht
Und zwar
Auf Facebook steht ich wäre angeblich
Angeblich bin ich Sponsort
Bei Alienware
Überhaupt nicht
Ich wollt mal vor Uhrzeiten was machen mit Alienware
Ich glaube das hab ich damals
Als Demo reingemacht
So könnte man das machen
Aber wir haben da nie was zusammen gemacht
Oh gibt's ihn eigentlich noch
Der ist auch mal
Der ist auch mal auf Twitch gewesen
Und dann hab ich nie mal was von ihm gesehen
Verklagen
Was soll ich verklagen
Alienware
Du musst dann bei Linked
Das ist korrekt
Und dann mach ich dann beim nächsten
Stellenanzeigen Video
Dann such ich als Flutter App
Programmierer mal einen Job
Leute weißt du was man
Echt ohne Scheiß
Wisst ihr was man machen müsste
Den Linkedin Account erstellen
Reinschreiben
Flutter
Flutter Kenntnisse
Und du suchst Job als Flutter Entwicklung
Und als Referenz
Machen wir die Qt App rein
Und dann meint ihr
Da melden sich irgendwelche Headhunter
100 pro oder
Die schreiben doch eh random einfach nur Leute an
Ohne sich das genauer anzugucken
Ich schreib rein
15 Jahre Flutter
Enterprise Business
Experience
Als Chief Flutter
Technology
Engineer
Programmer
Und dann geb ich als Referenz
Ayaya App an
30 Jahre Flutter
15 Jahre reichen nicht
Und ich mein ihr müsst euch mal angucken
Was für ein geiles Feature
Man kann auf den Button klicken
Für den Sound
Und man kann auf das Bild klicken
Also das ist besser als VLC schon mal
Und es ist responsive
So halbwegs zumindest
Also ich finde es ist schon eindeutig besser
Als VLC
Wobei VLC verwenden die
Die coolen Leute auf LinkedIn nicht
Besser als Apple Music
Wusstet ihr eigentlich
Dass die Sounds in Apple Betriebssystemen
Früher
Total viele Beatles Referenzen hatten
Nur um Anwälte abzufacken
Habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gelesen
Ich lese auch Videos
Kein Problem
Habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen
Weil Apple musste damals sagen
Sie gehen nie ins Musikbereich
Weil
Das Plattenlabel der Beatles
Wohl Apple hieß
Apple sagte sie machen nichts
Musikmäßiges
Und um die Anwälte abzufacken
Haben sie dann
Die ganzen Sounds
Unter dem alten MacOS Betriebssystem
Irgendwelche Referenzen auf Beatles Songs
Um die Anwälte zu ärgern
Letztes Video gelesen
Oh warum ging das jetzt nicht
Kein Cloud-Native-Button.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind, wenn es kompiliert, dann geht es offensichtlich.
Ja, ja, das ist aber auch von 2006.
Das ist ja schon relativ neu.
Läuft OVH wieder komplett?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Schimmer.
Ich habe bei OVH nichts.
Und wisst ihr, warum ich bei OVH nichts habe?
Ich versuche es euch mal zu zeigen, kurz.
Ich wollte mir bei OVH was mieten.
Ja.
Und OVH hat gesagt...
Okay, die sind vielleicht immer noch down.
Tja, anscheinend wollen die das jetzt gar nicht mehr weiter wissen.
OVH hat gesagt, ich soll meinen Ausweis kopieren und ihnen schicken.
Für einen popeligen 2 Euro VVM.
Und da habe ich gesagt, nee.
War ich nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich...
Und deswegen läuft der Preisschamp nicht bei OVH.
Naja, naja, ich sage mal so.
Also, offiziell ja, inoffiziell musst du das nicht.
Das habe ich gehört, ja.
Und ich habe mich wieder gefragt, warum lassen Leute ihr lokales Netzwerkequipment über die Cloud managen?
Ist das nicht komplett kontraproduktiv?
Irgendwie?
Warum macht man sowas?
Nein, nein, das ist auch bei alten YouTube-Accounts.
Also, wenn ihr ein YouTube-Video habt, was ab 18 ist, macht es einfach mit VLC auf oder mit irgendwas anderem.
Dann geht das auch.
Das müsst ihr nicht über YouTube gucken.
Und dann müsst ihr euch auch nicht anmelden und dann müsst ihr auch keinen Personalausweis angeben.
Aber offiziell muss man das dann.
Oder YouTube-DL-Downloaden.
Ja, man nennt das doch umgangssprachlich Rootserver.
Gar nicht.
Closed Source.
Huge Dongs.
Cute Chat Limited.
In England.
Am Start.
Also, ich bin bei allem mittlerweile bei Hetzner und ich finde die vom Preis her echt in Ordnung.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, warum man sein Netzwerkmanagement für lokale Netzwerkequipment-Gear über die Cloud laufen lässt,
es entzieht sich komplett meinem Verständnis, ja.
Also, ich mag Hetzner allein schon, nachdem das andere RZ abgeraucht ist, mehr.
OVA hat wohl angeblich eine super DDoS-Protection.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das Video mache ich jetzt nicht auf.
Ich weiß nicht, was da Sache ist.
Ja, einfach Cloudflare.
Kommt drauf an.
Die einfache DDoS-Protection von Cloudflare macht halt auch kein Magic.
Und viele Zusatzfunktionen bei Cloudflare musste...
zusätzlich kaufen.
Also, wir haben es letztens mal getestet, also mit jemand aus dem Stream,
der Zugriff auf so ein paar zehntausende Polenrechner oder so hatte.
Keine Ahnung, wo das hergekommen ist.
Und das ist einfach ratzfatz durch Cloudflare durch.
Und hat das Ding lahmgelegt im Preischamp.
Aber das lag halt daran, das waren legit Anfragen.
Und ich hätte in Cloudflare auf Attack schalten können.
Das hätte funktioniert wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber das muss ich ja manuell machen.
Und OVA hatte angeblich einen super ausgeklügelten Schutz gegen sowas.
Habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert.
Und sie müssen zumindest ein ziemlich fettes Netzanbindung haben.
Und ordentlich fettes Netzwerkequipment, dass einiges abkann.
Also, das würde ich sagen, wäre es mal wert ausprobiert zu werden.
Aber ich würde sagen, das ist ein guter Weg.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein guter Weg.
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein, jetzt zu OVA zu wechseln.
Ich weiß nicht, was der hatte.
Ich will es auch gar nicht zu genau wissen, ehrlich gesagt.
Hä?
Was bezieht sich das jetzt?
Achso, du meinst die Leute, die YouTube, ja.
Gut, die haben halt Pech.
Die haben halt Pech.
Ja, das ist irgendeine spanische Seite oder italienisch.
Ich verstehe da nur die Hälfte.
Sind Bilder.
Sind Bilder vom OVA Rechenzentrum oder sowas.
Mit was auch immer.
Mit was auch immer ich da sehe.
Das ist das RZ, das abgebrannt ist.
Ja, anscheinend war nicht genug Brandprotection, ja.
Ja gut, mit Wasser kommt man ja da eh nicht weit.
Und außerdem, naja.
Der Boden ist auch geil, Alter.
Null.
Was ist das für ein Boden, ne?
Ist das Wolle oder?
Nee, ist Holz.
Naja.
Kann, ey, das kann letztendlich.
Mehr oder weniger jedem Anbieter mal passieren.
Du musst immer abwiegen.
Abwiegen zwischen, äh.
Wie viel kost's?
Und, und.
Wie.
Also was lässt es dir kosten, dein schlechtes Bauchgefühl zu beseitigen, ja?
Also, pff.
Ja, letztendlich kann das schon verstehen, dass das so weit gekommen ist.
Ja.
Nachher kann man immer meckern.
Klar, aber auf der anderen Seite, guck mal, wenn sie es teurer gebaut hätten,
hätte man sich da vielleicht gar keine Server gekauft, weil es so teuer ist.
Also das ist immer so ein, immer so ein Hin und Her.
Das kann dir letztendlich mit fast jedem Anbieter passieren.
Dass da irgendwas so verkackt wird, dass die Kisten weg sind.
Pech gehabt.
Deswegen sollte man sich halt auch nicht auf eine Kiste an einem Standort verlassen.
Übrigens, äh, Rechenzentrum mit Teppichboden, da kenne ich auch was.
Da könnte ich mal ein Video drüber machen, eigentlich.
Rechenzentrum mit Teppichboden, naja.
Genau, also ich kenne das auch, äh, Rechenzentrum mit Teppichboden.
Und zwar, als ich noch da, wo ich die Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht habe, da gearbeitet habe.
Die haben für, für eine Stadt, haben die, ähm, den IT-Service-Zeug mitgemacht.
Und, ähm, dass die in der Nähe Storage und Server aufstellen konnten, haben die sich einfach eine Wohnung gemietet.
Und haben dort Racks.
Reingestellt.
Mitten in die Wohnung.
Da war Teppich im Rechenzentrum.
Und das Storage-System wurde mit einem Kran durchs Fenster reingehoben.
Hat, glaube ich, noch die Fensterbank kaputt gemacht dabei.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
So ist das halt als Computer-Fuzzi, ja.
So, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt off.
Und morgen muss ich wieder arbeiten, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber so ist es halt.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.